life is crazy everyone's crazy I just
they are try and play low and mind my
own business that's what I always say I
try to keep my distance yeah and like do
my own thing I think life is really fast
for her right now I think she's really
driven and doesn't know what's driving
her if you don't know what's driving you
I think it's it's definitely hard to
feel what are you doing it all for right
but then again it's not
really my life to live so yeah I feel
the same again I think when it when it
bumps into my life that's when I'm like
uh affected otherwise I'm like oh just
everyone do whatever makes you happier
you know I feel like beyond that it
really doesn't affect my life and I
think I stay a little away like you do
just to have your own life your own
friends your own thing it's healthy to
have your own identity yeah absolutely